buonasera vi starete chiedendo che fine
hanno fatto i video del canale
principale
ebbene lo studio nuovo e lo sfondo nuovo
non sono ancora finiti per lo sfondo
manca poco per lo studio invece non ci
hanno ancora attaccato internet fastweb
priamo e siccome ho avuto la brillante
idea di iniziare questo nuovo progetto
dello studio con i nuovi video a fine
luglio
e siccome poi c'è agosto che è il
periodo in cui youtube non se lo caga di
pezza nessuno diciamo che ho fatto una
cazzata
quindi le trasmissioni regolari
riprenderanno da settembre e dove
disponibile a colori nel formato pal
durante tutto il mese di agosto invece
ci saranno altri tipi di video video
leggeri o video perduti
insomma video del ca oppure di vostra
volontà potreste andare a vedere altri
canali
però basta che poi non venite a rompere
i se fanno cagare anch'essi in
formato palla grazie mille
e buona serata